تكون تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعيه الجديد قوه
من اجل الخير لكنها تحمل ايضا في طياتها
جوانب مظلمه الحديث لفيرا جروفا نائبه
رئيس المفوضيه الاوروبيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
طالب شركات التكنولوجيا الكبرى بتحذير
المستخدمين بشان المحتوى الذي يتم انشاؤه
بذكاء الاصطناعي والذي قد يؤدي الى
معلومات مضلله او تقول نائبه رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ان الذكاء الاصطناعي
تسبب بتكوين مخاطر جديده وامكانيه حدوث
عواقب سلبيه على المجتمع بسبب تزييف
المعلومات واضافت ان شركات ميتا الملكه
لفيسبوك ومايكروسوفت وتيك توك عليها ان
تتخذ اجراءات بشان هذا الامر كما قال ان
شركتين مايكروسوفت وجوجل اللتين يتضمن
الذكاء الاصطناعي في خدماتها عليها ضمان
وعدم استخدام هذه التقنيه في انشاء مواد
خميسه على
حد وصفها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات